Film Courage: Is there a specific structure
you use in your screenplays?
Gary Goldstein: Yeah.
Generally I defer to the classic storytelling
structure which is the 3-act structure, the
different series of movements across the whole
script, I break it down into 3 acts, 4 quarters,
12 sequences.
I try to mix it up a little.
But I’m a big believer in drawing inside
the lines and then messing it up.
At least knowing that you’ve got your framework
the way that most stories are told best and
most effectively and you can kind of mess
it up and smudge it up and put your stamp
on it, you know.
I’m not such a big believer that what is
supposed to happen on page 60, happens exactly
on page 60.
Well if it’s page 58 or 63 or if it’s
based upon the length of the script, page
42.
As long as the movements or the proportion
of your story is right, the movements are
kind of traditional…not traditional, classical
storytelling.
Because tradition always sounds like you’re
in a box.
That to me is important.
But I’m a big believer in structure.
I believe you get really found out why your
story isn’t working when you kind of don’t
follow some kind of classic storytelling structure.
Film Courage: So going back to when you were
at the writer’s bootcamp, how would you
know if a story was great, but it just needed
to have more structure infused in it?
Gary Goldstein: Well, I believe you can structure
any story.
You have to have enough of a way to expand
that story into a full movie.
You know, sometimes you watch a movie and
you go “Nothing happened in that movie.”
Or “What a bunch of nothing.”
It was really because there may not have been
enough story.
My very first screenplay, I had three different
ideas for scripts and I ended up putting all
three together and I found my story.
Individually each story may not have been
enough.
Some how or another, all three of those ideas
together just sort of fit like this puzzle
and I was able to create this script.
So there is that approach to it.
But basically, you know a good story when
you hear it or you know the beginnings of
a good story or a story that has potential
or an interesting character.
A lot of stories are just set up.
It’s like “Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah…”
“Well, that’s great.
But what happens then?”
Because that’s only taking me through the
first act.
The second act is always the most difficult
act if you don’t know where you are going.
And most anybody can write the first act of
a script.
But it’s where it goes from there that’s
tricky.
Sometimes an idea might just be all set-up
and there’s nothing beyond that.
But if you take another idea and pair it and
another idea and bring it in and kind of layer
it, then you may have more of that story.
It’s about finding the story.
Like I said, you can structure anything.
You can create a structure as long as there’s
enough story and finding that story, which
is the challenge.